hi I'm Francisco Rodriguez I will talk
about your data and how much new your
graphical that we are adding to the
working language and I work in the war
intercepts research South America office
and one of the things I do it's all is
related to your data
so today I want to review most of what
we have added to to this field since
well things Mathematica tango when we
have started and then all these
geographical data is about while we put
in the maps so what are what are these
map elements since they're something of
mathematical language we started having
all these Geographics functionality and
in general we have two main things in
the Maps the background which are tiles
which is a relief plot outline and
something over the map which is a
graffiti that might be a general
graphics like a point lying or
Geographics primitive like a your path
your circle etc and in this case which I
will talk more it's about the entities
the entities that come from the Wolfram
language knowledge base and that are
share with a wall from alpha so the main
two functions we have in now for
accessing all these backgrounds all
these maps are yaw graphics and your
image your graphics has been there for a
while this is a simple call then we are
going to see more examples and with your
graphics there are many other functions
that start using your graphics like your
lease plot your histogram dynamic
Geographics which is another way to to
use your graphics and something that is
new in these
latest release still target us
experimental is they your image function
the way of yo image is to return only
the image itself many times when we want
to do something with the maps what we
want is the image and start playing and
start using image processing tools etc
so before you need to do you your
graphics and then try to extract the
stuff from the output but now we are
allowing direct extraction of this then
something else is that we need data to
put in the maps so there are many ways
to access this data for example we have
the general function entity value or
this way to access the for example the
polygon the position etc from the
entities then we have more specialized
functions like your nearest and some of
these related functions so that I can do
for example I want to look up for the
nearest city to the 0 0 position in the
latitude longitude well and it will give
me that that entity for example this is
a city in in Ghana yes in Ghana or if I
want for example give me the oceans
closer to the South Pole so I can use
also name at your positions and get the
five oceans starting for the nearest to
the South Pole oceans and seas in
general also there are other functions
like your entities for example if I want
to extract to search for all the
mountains in Antarctica then I can
extract them with your entities and for
example do an ice your list plot for
them with the background of the of the
Antarctica
of course all these functions your
graphics and related functions have many
many options I'm not talking about the
options in this talk general but in the
examples you will see them
for example the projection the
production in this case is very
important if we project Antarctica with
the regular Mercator projection we
cannot for example see the South Pole
itself we need to have the proper
projection for the for each map we have
other functions for example travel
directions travel directions allows you
to plan a path between two positions for
example I could even put two very far
away both cities like Mallory tension
guy and I can have a path computed for
traveling from one place to the other
using your path which is one of these
more you graphics primitives I can show
that in the map so if I want to go by
car from Madrid to Shanghai I may follow
this path and how much is that in
distance well I can query that it's like
12,000 kilometers that's a long way and
I may ask how long will take like six
days I don't think that's planning any
sleeping so probably it's going to be
doable and then we have another function
to access more of these graphical data
which is elevation data generation data
allows me to access we have internal
servers we have data for all the world
so for example for here I can request
what's the value of the elevation in
this in this place it's 200 meters so we
are very very low elevation and also
there is a second parameter in this
elevation data which allows you to
access different types of elevation
because you know it's not the same
television from the above the sea level
done above the ellipsoid of reference of
the world so there is a model of the
world not a sphere but ellipsoid and we
can measure also the the difference
between these two types of elevation one
is called oolitic the usual one that is
the one that we see in a book is usually
the ortho metric the undulation is the
difference between these two types of
elevation and I can also request my
distance to the center of the earth also
there is a third parameter that allow
you to have different types of return
data so if I want not the data the
values but a nice reading option object
I can which I can play with I can do
computation with all these geometric
computation we have now for trillions I
can request that in the argument and for
example here I'm drawing the chimborazo
volcano which it's a nice what kind of
because it has the most it's a point
that is more away from the center of the
earth so you may think that that point
will be the reverse but that's not true
and we can compute that using the center
parameter of elevation data and indeed
is two kilometers further than average
from the center of there and that's
because the form of the earth which is
not a perfect sphere and another way to
access your graphic data which is newing
11 2 is the yesung import-export so this
is a new addition in in the
import-export framework that we work it
from the geographic side because we are
very interested on I mean this interface
with a standard program so Eurasian is a
standard format use it to interchange
your graphical data and now we have the
capability to export an
or that for example I can export an
empty map and the only thing that we are
exporting in that case is the bounding
box so at least we are showing the
bounding box which is part of the
Eurasian standard but I can also for
example export a polygon like for
example the polygon off my car with your
graphics that's going to be a hundred
kilobytes file for example in case I
write like that to a file and this is a
snippet of how it looks so it has the
this JSON format of tax and data and the
coordinates of course within the
geometry type polygon and I can import
it as any import format it has the
elements request so I can see what what
are they think that I can port from it
and the default is use the yo graphics
map the same that will be done if I use
run this in a standalone way
it's insane
it's not
we're neighbors right now and then I can
get the data itself from from this Oh
Jason
I mean that guy's I get the the polygon
back from that geometry
okay
now talking about the tiles I only map
as background we use tiles and in
general we are handling the conventional
types of 256 pixels by 256 big pixels
and well in general they are split that
way because in that way we can have many
many zooms many zoom levels and have
more and more precice Maps and of course
if I go to this is for some two three
four I would add if I want to draw the
entire map event alene millions of types
but that allows me to zoom in in a map
or main and default time set comes from
Open Street Map but we have on tiles
server so what we did was we have all
the OpenStreetMap data and we are
building all ties or self so in that way
we can have our own style or own layers
etc in general some saviola are from 1
to 18 and you can access these this ties
using the stream map stream map no
labels and stream map labels only in
general on each zoom we add more and
more detail so not only more resolution
but also more detail so for example
capital cities maya period sum for all
roads at some 5 countries start
appearing early in some tree and we can
also compute for example the size of a
pixel in each zoom so we could say that
one pixel in some one corresponds to 78
kilometers that will be at equator of
course while some 18 will be less than
one meter
that's quite a
and for example I can have a manipulate
of all these layers for example if I
don't want they was
and then I can access all these they are
from working for the defense ohms of
course there s not much in the tower
without any they would
so right now everything that is related
with the entity value is using its own
framework for for caching and for the
ties we are doing a session catching
only so so right now it's within the
same session you will have a faster maps
if you already have computed that but we
are not exposing any way to to have a
persistent kajak and that's also because
I'm going to show later we are going to
we allow also access to all different
servers for example and some of them
they don't allow you to to have a long
term catch a for example they all for
example we have a service that only
allows you one-hour catch a cold eyes
are because you were using is I think
one one day so if you keep your session
for more than one day it's some of the
tires
now we are using our own server we have
our own server for for the types we are
using the OpenStreetMap data which is
the same one for example used by map
books so so we are using this the same
data but with our own with our own tile
generation so we have our own game to
generate all the types this happy to
slowly Network what we might
yes there is that the servers will be in
the same colocation as well for an alpha
so we might access them in
and then the all the network issues
okay and we not only have a stream of
data but also satellite data and we have
also satellite data for other bodies not
only for the earth but now we have for
the moon Mars Mercury and Pluto and the
plan is to add more and more data for
all the planets all the moons etc yeah
which one the previous maps or all this
history map data is really OpenStreetMap
data but we are generating the ties
itself so so we open the map data is
free to use but the ties are ours that's
right
yes I know
I will talk a bit more I will talk about
more about the elevation data later okay
I have to hurry I think and well this is
a an increase in zoom for each of these
satellite maps of course we don't have
the same zoom level for every map and
with our own satellite data we have only
up to 11 for for the earth for the moon
we have up to nine up to eight etc for
each of these bodies we might access
also external servers with from yo
graphics so with the yo server option we
might specify other servers for example
this topo map or stamen which has
different style different date etc so
that's possible and we have added
something new in the latest version of
Wolfram language which is a an external
tie
service which is a et globe is the
backend for for this and this is doing
experimental testing pairs which means
that we are not charging anything for
for this but we are limiting the access
to only 3,000 times per month per user
we need access to the cloud to request
the data the satellite images and we
might have a better and very improved
resolution up to 18 for satellite image
they also provide other layers like a
strip map layer they are building also
using Open Street Map data so I'm going
to be the same but with a different
style another more still I sit there and
the different layers also for satellite
data and we might have for example the
same place in
I have a nice view of for example of the
London Tower at some 18 so this allows a
very improve satellite resolution
imagery
no no I think if the service provides
more soon you might use that as an
option so if you connect to another
external your server and it has some 30
you might use that it will work then now
all the entities we have plenty and it
is coming from Wolfram Alpha with
position but not all the entity has this
position value I have here a table with
the number of entities and the number of
entities with that position value set in
some cases is the same nothing mother
and so if you example for example if I
want to see a do a histogram of all the
nuclear explosions in the system and and
we have for example using the entity
value in the entity class of the latest
nuclear process we can see that all of
them are from North Korea no one else is
now doing that also we can have your
entities again with weather stations for
example for Fiji it's very nice that we
even spot islands that are even smaller
than the points and about entities with
polygons we have all these domains that
have a polygon but not all of them have
the polygon set for example one case
that we want to improve more still
ongoing city data only have a few with
polygons other cases have everything set
and for example I can draw a polygon of
an ocean a polygon well some cities like
Moscow or historical countries like for
example erawan kingdom from you 15 and
something is that we were missing in
country data for many many years and we
are having this is still not on
production but it's ongoing
it's a deletion of some countries that
are considered as part of the ISO
standard but that we were missing
because they are really dependencies
from
but in some data sets external data says
you have for example reference to them
so we need to have them also in the
system so we are adding them now it's
probably going to be in the next release
of Wolfram Alpha and these are the
different Maps the principal area and
the refill map area for these Island
countries you know island dependencies
also there are other types of
backgrounds which are the outlying
backgrounds like for example coastlines
country borders which allow me to have
well country borders which allow me to
to move for example to change the
projection without any distortion of the
of the map
or dated country borders for example the
one we suffer for our own Kingdom
now really
we have a standard resolution that it's
like if we put the map in a complete
screen it will look more or less nice
that's the idea of current resolution so
we can have the history of the borders
of the countries in different centuries
and two to end very quickly we have
added a lot of high resolution elevation
image now it's up to some 12 it means
that every pixel will be around 32
meters around the equator for example
this is for for Lima this is a there is
a an Avenue here to go down to the beach
and we can have different views and
here's the actual satellite image you
can extract different facts from the
elevation and we have added also
elevation for different bodies in the
solar system so for the earth for Moon
or Mars for macula and Pluto we
different zoom levels in the case of
Pluto we don't have data for all the
values because well it's very far so
there is only one mission that try to
gather the data and we might for example
place solar system scenes in these maps
in the satellite and compare them them
with the with the elevation map and well
I'm really out of time so thanks for
here
[Applause]
well you are invited to huh
question while working okay
- which of the datasets - to Elevation
well that's more data issues so because
we want to cover all the all the earth
so we don't have access to there is no a
dataset that covers in the resolution we
want all the earth so there are so much
to say for example for for us you have
like 15 for and we need to mix these
datasets oh yeah
yes
well we already have military conflicts
but if you want to your only and yeah
yes no yes yes that's well that's
something cover by Tony his talk that is
about the entity store so there is now
away
yes entity sorry process yes yes indeed
with the entity store and with all the
new mechanism you can interact your own
data with warfront data and with all
these functions for geographical
plotting and stuff yes yes there is a
version of entities are already working
right to complain with the polygons we
have with the same format of course yes
and there are some functions to to
import/export all that data
okay
that's a tricky question well Eurasian
is really add a new addition and we are
trying to make it also efficient and and
that's but it's use the first version of
this so we are still working on that
shapefile it's an old format that it was
already supported but somehow I think a
Eurasian for example supports all these
bounding box that didn't have the shape
files and so depends on what's your
actual application I think okay well
thanks for hearing now I invite you to
the next talk josè that it's also
related with all these your computation
[Applause]